okay so I want to summarize and review
what we have learned so far so the main
message is that for most of human
history we have been peaceful
egalitarian and artistic so about
300,000 years ago our species homoa
sapiens uh we were born in Africa
and then um 50,000 years ago because of
climate
change um we started to spread around
the world okay and throughout most of
our
history um we have been hunter
gatherers and we don't know that much
about our history we can only guess but
based on the available archaeological
evidence we we have we were for most of
the time peaceful egalitarian and
artistic okay so peaceful does not mean
we were not violent there's lots of
evidence that there was ingroup
conflict um so for example we discovered
uh in
burials people with skull fractures okay
so there's been violence but there's
been no no evidence of organized Warfare
that comes much later okay that's the
first thing second thing is that we were
egalitarian meaning that there was no
difference in status and power between
men and women men and women were
considered
equal there was no hierarchy meaning
that there were people who are
considered more wealthy than other
people we know because we could not find
any evidence of um hierarchy meaning
larger houses meaning groups with
special
privileges now there are
individuals who might have higher status
and we know because they were buried
more elaborately than other people so
for example shamans right shamans were
their religious leaders and as such they
were accorded higher status than
everyone else
Okay the third thing is
Artistic so as we know they were engaged
in cave paintings they built monuments
in order to celebrate and worship their
religion so for them art really was
about the expression and
celebration of their religion okay so
for most of human history we were
peaceful egalitarian and artistic and we
know that today we are not peaceful we
are not egalitarian we are not that
artistic so what
changed next week I'll explain to you
what changed okay basically a new group
of uh people called the yamaya came came
into being and they had a different
religion that celebrated Warfare P
patriarchy and wealth okay and
eventually spread all around Europe and
Asia and they conquered everyone and
they created a new history of humanity
that's next week okay so I want to um
explain the evidence for why we think
most of human history we were peaceful
otan and artistic okay so something else
that we discussed um in class is we
don't know what their religion uh was
but we suspect that it was animism and
Shamanism okay remember that animism is
the belief that we all come from the
mother goddess from one source of life
including trees animals and humans so
every living being has a
soul okay and the other thing is that
the soul is permanant you can never kill
it okay the body and the Soul are
different so it doesn't really matter
matter if you die because your soul will
go somewhere else and maybe come back
okay so death was not a big deal and the
third thing is that there's a spirit
world or Another World which is more
real than our world okay our world is
just a manifestation a physical
manifestation of the spirit world but
what matters is a spirit world and the
last thing is
that there's a order to the universe we
have a part to play so for example we
can kill animals to feed ourselves but
we must pay tribute to these animals
before and after we kill them in order
to maintain the harmony of the
universe okay so that's what what we
believe the religion of early humans
were everywhere in the world okay
including in China including in Europe
um this is
goe and you can see that this is a te
pillar um and it's meant to represent a
human and inside the te pillar is an
animal so basically the te pillar
represents um the manifestation of the
animal spirit in us and we believe that
this is a religious Festival that they
would have before they went hunting the
evidence for this is that other site we
found a lot of animal BS
okay so does that make sense
guys all right so again this is all just
review um this religion goes back a long
time okay so this is 40,000 years ago we
found this small um figurine okay it's a
very small figurine in a cave in Germany
and this dates back to 40,000 years ago
okay so remember 50,000 years ago we
started to leave Africa and Venture
around Venture into Europe and around
the world okay so this goes back to the
beginning the dawn of humanity this is a
flute okay that goes back at to the same
time so at the beginning of humanity we
were religious we celebrated um our
religion through music and through ART
and through
Shamanism does that make sense guys
yes it's a figurine it's a
doll okay so they believe that these
dolls have religious qualities right
okay does that make sense it's like
paintings okay so um remember like they
also have these cave paintings where
they're celebrating the mother goddess
and they're sing the fact that life is a
circle after you kill the animals their
soul goes back into the spirit world and
then through uh proper trute and worship
you can bring them back into this world
okay okay this is um a shaman dressed as
an animal okay so now the question then
is okay if you if we cannot go back in
time and
um observe their religion how do we know
what their religion is and the answer is
we have a field of study called
anthropology okay anthropology
anthropology is a study of other
cultures if it and if our theory is
right then we should be able to find
other cultures that are still alive
today that practice this religion and
what we've discovered is that if you go
to
to um places in the
jungle um in South America and in Africa
in Australia they do practice this
religion okay so understanding the
religion gives us tremendous insight
into the thinking uh and Religion of
Early Humans and that's what we will do
today okay to truly understand what
early humans thought
um and how they understood the world
okay does that make sense guys all right
so the first passage we're going to look
at
is um from a book called The wayfinders
by Wade Davis okay this is a great book
if you if you guys ever have a chance
please read this book okay it's
extremely well written um way Davis he's
an anthropologist
Canadian um and this recently came out
okay so he spent a lot of time uh
traveling around the world to explore
and to understand indigenous peoples
people who are native to the land and
they've been there for a long long time
so this is what he says about a tribe in
the Amazon forest okay in the beginning
before the creation of Seasons before
the ancestral mother Romi kumu woman
Shaman opened her womb before her blood
and breast milk gave rise to rivers and
her ribs to the mountain ridges of the
world there was only chaos in the
universe spirits and demons known as hul
prayed on their own Kindred bred without
thought committed incest about
consequence devoured their own young
Roman kumu responded by destroying the
world with fire and floods then just as
a mother turns over warm slap all of
maniac bread on the gridle she turned
the inated and charred world upside down
creating a flat and empty template from
which life could emerge once again as
woman Shaman she then gave birth to a
new world land water forest and animals
okay so this is what we call a creation
myth and every single civilization every
single people have
a creation myth so let me ask you this
question okay why why do you need a
creation
myth what's this crean myth doing what
does it
explain okay how the world forms okay
but it does something much more
important than that which is
what excuse
me who are we where we come from yes but
there something it yes it explains all
that who we are where we come from okay
that's what all creation myths do what
else is this myth doing which is very
important for
us excuse
me okay so it's telling us How the
Universe was formed
okay what is in here that's very
important and which is important for
society to function well
okay so the woman Shaman is a mother
godess but what's in this
paragraph that's very important in order
for society to function what do you need
for society to
function you need rules and laws right
so what this chistian myth is doing what
all chisan myths is doing is build
explaining to you the legal structure of
your Society why you can't do certain
things okay so for example you can't um
commit incest okay you can't eat your
young people you can't kill the young
people okay why because that's what evil
people do you understand so what this
Christian myth is doing is it's
basically
explaining the legal system the rules
and why we have them we have these rules
because they're evil they represent the
evil
spirit okay does that make sense guys
okay the other thing that you will
notice about this creation myth is that
it's very sophisticated and very
elaborate okay so this is a
visualization of their understanding of
creation and as you can understand it's
very complicated okay does that make
sense why is it complicated
why is it complicated
why is this so
complicated there there there are
reasons for it
why okay so one thing that you will
learned in this class is that what's
really important is for you to believe
that your religion is correct okay it is
just correct as science and what makes
people believe that your religion is
correct um you have you have to
accomplish three things okay the first
is
grandness meaning that is com huge okay
it's vast and as you can see this is a
vast religion a vast cosmology of how
things started so grandness is very
important then you have then you you
then you need
completeness and the idea of
completeness is that everything that you
see in the world must be explained in
this cosmology okay so what this is
doing is explaining to you how
everything started okay where everything
comes from so completeness is important
last thing is Unity meaning that there's
a beginning and there's an
end okay as you can see there's a
beginning and then there's an end okay
so this is something that we will learn
in this class as we explore other
religions including uh Judaism and
Christianity where for religion to be
powerful for it to be authoritative you
need these three ideas grandness
completeness and unity okay does that
make sense all right let's keep let's
keep on
going all right so thus for the people
living today in the forest of the par
Parana okay this is the Amazon forest
the entire natural world is saturated
with meaning and cosmological
significance okay they feel that
everything around them has life and it's
all connected it's one unified hole
okay every Rock and waterfall embodies a
story plants and animals are but
distinct physical manifestations of the
same essential spiritual Essence okay we
all come from the woman Shaman we all
come from the mother goddess therefore
we all have the spark of life in us and
therefore we must be respected okay the
plants and the animals all must be
respected as much as we are respected at
the same time effing is more than it
appears for the visible world is only
one level of perception behind every
tangible form Tang means concrete
physical okay every PL and animal is a
shadow dimension a place invisible to
Ordinary People but visible to the
shaman so in other words our world is a
world we can see but there are other
worlds the Shadow Dimension which is
more real which captures our Essence
where the soul resides okay that's more
real and it's a job of the shaman to see
and communicate with this
world this is the realm of the H Spirits
a world of deified ancestors where rocks
and rivers are alive plants and animals
are human beings sap and blood the
bodily fluids of the primor river of the
anacon hidden in cataracts behind the
physical veil of waterfalls in the very
center of stones are the great malakas
of the H spirit where everything is
beautiful The Shining feathers the Coca
the Calabash of tobacco powder which is
in itself the skull and brain of the sun
okay now reading
this what what can we say about their
religion what can we say about their
religion that would be surprising to
you okay first of all it's very
imaginative
right it's very
imaginative they have a vivid
imagination okay the other thing is that
it's extremely sophisticated and
complex so one
major um Prejudice that we might have
all these people is well they don't
drive cars they don't have cell phones
therefore they must be stupid but
clearly from our understanding of their
religious beliefs they're actually
extremely imaginative and extremely
sophisticated okay does that make sense
guys all
right so this is their shamans in
religious practice
okay what can we say about this
picture what stands out about this
picture what surprises you or what cap
what catches your eye about them what
what can we say about their beliefs
based on this
picture okay yeah
so there's a lot
of
um there's a lot
lot of thought put into what they wear
right okay so again
sophistication their clothing the way
they dress suggests that this is a very
sophisticated religion okay it's not
like they just put on anything it's like
it seems they put a lot of care and
thought into what they wear okay that's
the first thing what's the other thing
what's the other
thing excuse
me well there AR that many of them
there's three of them but what do you
notice about the way they look in their
bodies and the way they stand in
relationship to each
other what do you notice yeah
um okay yeah I mean he probably has a
higher status okay and he stands in the
middle okay what
else excuse
me okay so
um the so you're right in like okay if
this is a tribe and all they're trying
to do is hunt and eat food none of this
makes makes any sense right but the main
argument that I've been trying to tell
you is like no their first priority is
their religion okay so everything they
do has a religious significance to it we
don't know what it is they don't really
speak our language but for them
everything that they do must have a
religious meaning okay so it's the
religion that centers their
life so the other thing I I would say is
you can see there's some organization in
order to it right so as you say the
person the Elder stands in the middle
okay and these two can you see the
Symmetry okay it's clear that they are
doing a religious ceremony and because
of this religious ceremony requires
their bodies to be a certain way in
relation to each other it requires them
to dress a certain way it requires them
to say certain things okay clearly they
are in prayer of some sort we call this
the idea of
ritual ritual is just the expression of
religion in everyday practice in other
words their lives are extremely
ritualized meaning what they do every
second has a religious meaning and
religious
significance okay does that make sense
to you
guys right so for example you come to
school and you think your your life is
very ordered right because maybe at 8:00
you start class and then when class
starts the teacher takes
attendance okay that's all
ritual and then at 8:45 the bell rings
and then you go off and get some water
or something okay if you want to go to
the restroom you have to raise your hand
this is all what we call ritual so your
lives are extremely ritual ized the
thing about ritual is behind the ritual
there has to be a belief
system okay so for us the
school we believe the system is set up
so that you learn how to do well in life
right you learn how to be on time you
learn how to respect authority you learn
how to read books Okay so
this Society is in exactly the same way
where every minute of their lives
there's order and structure to what they
do that has meaning and purpose okay
does that make sense
guys
okay so uh let's talk about their ritual
okay is to the realm of the ho spirit
that the shaman goes in in ritual so the
shaman is responsible for entering the
world of the demons and negotiating and
communicating with them okay that's his
role that's why he has his power and
authority contrary to popular law in the
west the shaman of the barazana never
uses or manip manipulates medicinal
plants his duty and sacred pass is to
move in the Timeless Realm of the hull
embrace the primordial powers and
harness and restore the energy of all
creation he is like a modern engineer
who enters the deaths of a nuclear
reactor to renew the entire Cosmic order
okay
so if for example plants are dying
outside what does this mean if plants
are dying outside what does this mean
the animals and plants are dying
how can we fix a
problem why are bad things
happening bad things are happening
because the spirits are unhappy right
does that make sense so therefore you
must go into the spirit world and
understand why the spirits aren't
unhappy and fix it okay and that's the
role of the
shaman and what this is saying is this
what this is saying is that our world
doesn't matter guys okay our world is
insignificant what matters is the spirit
world because the spirit world is what
controls everything okay does that make
sense guys
okay among the barana such we knew is a
fundamental obligation of the living in
practice this implies that the barana
see the Earth as potent the force as
being alive with Spiritual Beings and
incestual powers to live off the land is
to embrace both its creative and
destructive potential human beings
plants and animals seeare the same
Cosmic origin in a profound sense are
seen as essentially identical responsive
to the same princi
obligated by the same duties responsible
for the collective well-being of
creation there is no separation between
nature and culture without the forest
and the rivers humans would perish
without people the natural world would
have no order or meaning all would be
chaos dozen Norms that drive social
behavior would have no order or meaning
sorry would also Define the manner in
which human beings interact with a wow
the plants and animals the multiple
phenomenon of the natural world
lightning and thunder the Sun and the
Moon the scent of a blossom the sou
order of death okay so everything is
connected with each other we're all
equals okay does that make sense guys
all right this is what we call
animism all right so let's talk about
hunting okay this is something we talked
about last class
if we are the same if we're if we are
the same as animals and plants what
allows us what gives us permission to
kill other animals okay and this passage
explains it when men go to the forest to
hunt or fish it is never a trivial
passage you you you you cannot just go
and Hunt okay you need permission first
the shaman must travel in trance to
negotiate with the masters of the
animals forging a mystical contract with
the spirit Guardians in exchange based
always on
reciprocity okay reciprocity means give
and take if I give you a present you
must give me a present okay the Brana
compared to marriage for hunting too is
a form of courtship in which one seeks
the blessings of a greater Authority for
the honor of taking into one's family a
precious being meat is not the right of
a hunter but a gift from the spirit
world to kill without permission is to
risk death by a spirit
Guardian be it in the form of a Jaguar
an aona Tapo or harpy eagle okay this
something that we discussed in the cave
paintings why did they spend so much
time painting these animals and we said
this it's because they're trying to pay
tribute to the animals right if I kill
you I must thank you for taking your
meat to replenish myself
but I also must ask for your forgiveness
otherwise the animal soul may seek
Vengeance okay does that make sense so
this is the essence of the
religion if we hunt we must first pay
tribute okay and that's and that's what
explains katah hoic right okay the bull
and the people before they go hunting
they must tribute to all the
animals okay this is TR and you also
look at the cave paintings right they
have all these cave paintings and what
they celebrate is not themselves what
they celebrate are the animals because
it's the
animals that give them life that give
them nourishment and meat okay does that
make sense
so and you can see this in caves all
around Europe and around the
world
okay all right as the ritual begins time
collapses there are two series of dances
separated by the Lial moments of the day
dawn dusk and midnight okay so the shock
in during the ritual is once needs to
communicate with the animals in the
spirit world okay to do that he changes
he changes from fish to animal to human
being and Back Again transcending every
form becoming pure energy flowing among
every dimension of reality past and
present here and there Mythic and
mundane his chance recall by name every
point of geography met on the ancestral
journey of the anaca okay so as you can
see before the hunt the ritual is
extremely elaborate sophisticated and
complex and its main purpose is to
celebrate the unity of life and to ask
permission and to ask for forgiveness as
the hunters go kill the animals okay
does that make sense guys and
again this explains
okay so so the shamans will change into
animals okay in order to better
communicate with the animals and this
explains all the cave
paintings and how 40,000 years ago they
were creating dolls of Shaman dressed as
animals okay because for them this is
what is
true
okay does that make sense guys all right
so any questions far before I move
on are you guys clear about what's going
on okay all
right now let's move to Africa okay we
were in South America and there're still
there today if you want to go visit that
tribe you can do so okay now let's go to
Africa and in Africa there's a group of
people called the pygmies okay the
pygmies um and there's a very famous
book by an a British
Anthropologist uh by the name
of um Colin chbo okay and he discusses
how the pig Mees practice the religious
religious beliefs at the very center of
the religion is something called the
mimo okay which is a trumpet-like
instrument and the mimo allows them to
communicate with the forest it allows
them to communicate with the spirit
world and that's how they resolved every
issue okay and um the mimo
also captures the sound and spirit of
the forest okay all right so um even
though we are in a different part of the
world we're in Africa and even though
the pygmies have different religious
beliefs than the people of the Amazon
what you will discover what you will
notice is that essentially the same
religion okay the same idea that we are
part of Nature and that our job is to
help nature maintain balance and
Harmony
okay okay so what I want to do now okay
is compare contrast the way we think
today and how they thought before okay
so let's read I had no idea of how far
we had come or in what direction so he's
following the group of pigs around as
they hunt but I knew we had left the
camp far behind it was the first time I
had known a group of pygmies to be so
silent normally unless hunting they are
deliberately noisy but now just at the
time that leopards would be prowling
about in search of food they seem
unwilling to do to disturb the forest or
the animals it concealed just the
opposite in fact it was as if they were
a part of the silence and the Darkness
of the forest itself and were only
fearful lest any sound might betray
their presence to some person or thing
not of the
forest they stood there quiet and still
and it struck me with a sudden shock
that not one of them carried a spear or
bow and arrow as they peered into the
dust and cocked their heads first on
this side then on that satisfying
themselves that we were really alone it
seemed that they felt themselves so much
AP part of the forest and of all the
living things in it they had no need to
fear anything except that which was not
of the forest one of them said to me
later when we are the children of the
forest what need have we to be afraid of
it we are only afraid of that which is
outside the forest okay so what I want
to do now is through by analyzing this
passage passage
explore how our minds are different from
their minds okay so our mind is what we
considered
modern and their mind is what what we
considered premodern
okay what's the first major difference
between I okay the British
Anthropologist and how we think and how
they think what's the first difference
you you notice from this
passage okay first of all what is the
word that tells us that he doesn't
really understand how these people think
and
behave what's the word that tells us he
doesn't really understand these people
this is actually a great sat question if
you guys plan on taking the SAT okay
there's a word in this passage that that
tells us he is actually he is actually
he doesn't really understand how these
people think and feel what's the
word shock right
shock okay so he's surprised by their
behavior why is he Sur
surprised what confuses
him
anyone why what yes exactly okay why
does that surprise
him exactly okay so here's the first big
difference why do we think the nature is
dangerous why do they not think nature
is dangerous what why
why guys that's exactly right okay he
thinks nature is dangerous because
they're leopards they're Predators okay
they don't think nature is dangerous
what's the
difference what's the
difference okay the ma first major
difference is this our minds think that
we are separate from nature okay man
versus nature man versus nature
but they think they are part of nature
okay so let me ask you this
question why do we fear nature what
makes us fear nature if I put you in a
forest you're afraid
why yes okay why are you afraid of the
unknown
okay you don't know what you encounter
but why does that make you
afraid okay why why would the unknown
make you
afraid what is that that we are obsessed
with excuse me
okay we're obsessed with control
right we have to control everything we
want to know something because we want
we want to control it okay we like
animals in the zoo right we do not like
animals in the forest we we can control
animals in the zoo we cannot control
animals in the forest okay so we're
obsess with control why aren't they
afraid of nature
what's their attitude what the pym's
attitude we want to control nature but
they they
what therefore
they okay the word where you the word is
trust right
trust they don't have to control nature
because they trust nature they believe
the
leopard know them and they know the
leopard
okay does that make sense okay so that's
the first major difference between our
world and their world and we've been
taught that nature is our enemy or
nature is outside US whereas they
believe that they are part of
nature okay does that make sense guys
all right let's move
on all right
so this is about their religious
practice okay so they have a meal
together and then they sing or they use
the malomo to make noises and they sing
and dance okay everyone ate his field as
and when he pleased a couple of the
older men saying they would wait until
the youngsters had finished before they
ate but they did not wait for long I was
told however that everyone had to eat
eat just as no adult male was allowed to
sleep but to sing while malomo was
singing was in progress Apparently one
of the greatest crimes that the pygmy
can commit if not the greatest is to be
found asleep when the malomo is singing
when the men stood up and miming as all
pigments love to do he showed how they
used to search for sleeping man a spear
under each arm and how if they found one
they would spear him in the stomach and
kill completely and forever I was told
that then his body would be buried under
the k m okay the K is a great fire in
which they practice their religion okay
and nobody would be allowed to mention
his death even to REM mark on his
absence the woman would be told that the
Momo itself the great animal of the of
the forest had carry off one of their
number but like the men they would ask
no questions and would never again
mention the missing men okay so in this
world the greatest crime you can commit
is not to kill
someone but to sleep during the
religion can someone
explain why that's the
case in this world okay the pygmy world
the worst thing you can do is
sleep why is that the case
okay let's just say that we're having a
class and one of you um is sleeping okay
and I get so
angry that I I want to kill that person
why would I want to do that what's my
logic it's disrespectful of
what okay it's dis respectful of my
authority that is true but then I just
ask a person to leave my class right I
shout that at that person but I want to
kill that person why what's
happened okay what is a
classroom what's a
classroom okay a place to study what
else what are we doing
now yeah but what is class what is what
is
classroom what allows a classroom to
exist
H what is the ritual we're practicing
okay so classroom you can understand as
the collective experience okay a
classroom happens when everyone is
participating in it does that make sense
that's what makes a classroom
alive so why would why would be angry if
one of you one of you is
sleeping but and why does that
matter if you're sleeping what do you
telling
me yeah you it's not a classroom it's
not real this discussion is not real
it's pointless you understand so that's
what's happening here they mmal singing
the ritual it's meant for everyone to
recognize that the religion is real it's
more real than
reality okay but if you're sleeping
you're saying no guys this doesn't
matter okay what we're doing does not
matter
and therefore what you're doing is
you're not committing violence on one
person you're committing violence on the
community you're committing violence on
the religion you're insulting the forest
you're insulting the God does that make
sense and that's the worst
crime because reality happens this
religion is only possible if everyone
believes that it is true if you're
sleeping it means you don't think it's
true and therefore you are first of all
rejecting the community right you're
telling you're telling everyone you're
all idiots okay second second is that
you might endanger the community because
you're insulting the
forest okay does that make sense guys
okay so for most of human of human
history people take their religion
extremely seriously so seriously that
they think it's more real than reality
as long as everyone believes in it it's
true but if someone doesn't believe in
it then we have to kill that person
because if he doesn't believe in it then
it might cause our religion to die okay
does that make sense any questions so
far any questions we're all clear right
okay and what I'm trying to show you is
the power of religion okay how once we
have the religious imagin ation we can
create things that are actually for us
more real than reality okay so that's
the second thing that's different about
us from other human beings for most of
human history we were spiritual okay
we're spiritual meaning like we believe
like the world of the spirits our soul
it exists okay today the word we use is
materialistic
materialistic and the idea of
materialistic is this if we cannot see
it okay it's not real okay God can't be
real because we can't find it the soul
can't be real because we can't measure
it imagination can't be real because we
don't know where it comes from does that
make sense and obviously okay obviously
this idea of materialism is wrong how
can you
say the imagination doesn't
exist but unfortunately we have
structured our society around this idea
all science okay when you go to science
class they teach you this okay if it's
real you can measure it you can see
it you can feel it but for most of of of
human history we didn't believe that we
thought like okay there is a spiritual
world and that matters just as much as
reality okay in fact it matters Pro it
probably matters more than
reality okay so the so this is making
sense right guys
okay
okay for a month I sat every evening at
the Kam moo listening watching
okay if I still had little idea of what
was going on at least I felt that ear of
importance and EXP and see every evening
when the woman shut themselves up
pretending that they were afraid to see
the animal of the forest every evening
when the men gathered around the for
fire pretending they thought that the
woman thought that the dream pites were
animals every evening when the trumpet
drum drain pipes imitated leopards and
elephants and buffaloes every evening
when all this make believe was going on
I felt that something very real and very
great was going on beneath it something
that everyone else took for granted and
about which only I was
ignorant okay clearly he does he does
not understand these people what word
tells us he doesn't understand these
people he doesn't know what's going on
why what what word tells us
this excuse me why is he
ignorant there's a word in here that
tells us he doesn't understand
understand this people at
all this word
shows that there's a Chasm okay a huge
difference between the pygmies and us
what is this
word what word would the pmics not use
here they've be insulted by this
word what's a word you use it over over
again right there's a word here that's
insulting
no what word here in this passage would
the pmies find
insulting so if another teacher comes in
to my class and he says wow your class
is a lot of
fun I've be insulted
why I've be insulted
why
no well you guys have so much fun in
this class you play a
lot I've be insulted
why ex
me you yeah this is not study okay this
is not serious academic work this is
playing it has no significance no
meaning right so what word implies that
here it repeats itself over and
over pretending right
pretending we think they're playing what
do they think
we think they're pretending we think
they're playing what do they
think they think it's all true you
understand for them their religion is
more true than this
world okay that's a power of the human
imagination you can imagine a world and
this world as long as many of you are
Imaging it together it's more true more
powerful more real than this world
that's a power of religion okay what we
call the religious imagination and we'll
see this over and over again in human
history okay does that make sense guys
Okay so we've been taught that oh you
can't see it it must be pretending it
must be make believe but for most of
human history for most people this is
not playing this is not pretending it's
true it's real it's what allows ows us
to be close to
God okay God is real this world we live
in it's not
real okay does that make sense guys all
right okay so let's look at the last
paragraph and then we'll finish and then
we'll finish for the day he went on to
tell that the pygmies called the malomo
whenever things seem to be going wrong
it may be that the is bad he said or
that someone is ill or as now that
someone has died these are not good
things and we like things to be good so
we call out the malimo and it makes them
good as they should be okay so this is
very similar to the shaman going into
the spirit world when things are bad
okay things are bad because the spirits
AR
happppy normally effing goes well in our
world in our forest but at night when we
are sleeping sometimes things go wrong
because we are not awake to stop them
from going wrong Army ANS invade the
camp leopards may come in and steal a
hunting dog or even a child if we were
awake these things would not happen so
when something big goes wrong like
illness or bad hunting or death it must
be because because the force is sleeping
and not looking after its children so
what do we do we wake it up we wake it
up by singing to it and we do this
because we want it to awaken happy then
effing will be well and good again so
when when our world is going well then
also we sing to the forest because we
wanted it to share our happiness okay do
you understand so this is like them
going to the spirit world and
communicating with the spirits so it's
almost the same religion
okay maybe the details are different but
the idea is the same the idea is that
we're all
interconnected animals plants humans all
the
same this is not the real world the
spirit world the forest they're the real
world and for us to maintain our health
and our happiness and our safety we must
always
communicate with this other world and
make sure they're
happy okay does it make
sense and because of this belief it
means we shouldn't go to war with other
people okay because because then that
causes um Mayhem and Chaos in the spirit
world our job is to maintain Harmony and
balance in this world we're caretakers
okay it means we should should not be in
conflict with each other we should be
equalitarian we should be equal because
we're all from the same mother goddess
we're all from the same Forest we're all
from the same from the same woman Shaman
okay it means we have to be artistic
because we have to
celebrate and worship the spirit world
does that make sense okay so again for
most of human history we were like this
and even today in a lot of cultures
around the world they're still like this
so now the question
is um what changed why do we have War
why do we have hierarchy why do why do
we have patriarchy why are men Superior
to women why do some rich people have
all the power okay this clearly goes
against this religion and what I will
show you um starting next class is the
beginning of a new
religion and how this new
religion that worships
wealth uh Power and War conquered
everyone okay does that make sense okay
any
questions before we
break anything you unclear
about
okay okay